il se trouve aux premières loges claude
lizotte a beau être témoin privilégié il
veut voir au delà de ce qu'ils lui
présentez vous êtes indécis je suis
absolument je suis très indécis je suis
très
suppose des choses là on part avec juste
une idée on dit les bélougas disparaît
prouve moines dans sa cour arrière
gros-cacouna
port en eau profonde qui n'a jamais
vraiment trouvé sa vocation devenu
aujourd'hui le symbole du dilemme entre
le développement économique et la
protection d'environnement c'est entre
autres à partir d'ici que le géant
albertain transcanada veut exporter du
pétrole canadien vers de nouveaux
marchés
et aujourd'hui on évolue tout le monde
évolue à toute évolution qu'on veuille
qu'on le veuille peau ça veut dire
dérange c'est un projet de 12 milliards
de dollars le plus important du genre en
développement en amérique du nord
l'enjeu est économique mais aussi
éminemment politique et les
préoccupations environnementales
attise les débats les prochaines étapes
soulève déjà bien des questions tous les
moyens sont déployés pour convaincre les
citoyens le promoteur transcanada les
informent à sa manière le pipeline
énergie est traverserait six provinces
et rien qu'au québec environ 170
municipalité 4 600 km de l'est au
dioxyde transporter du pétrole de
l'ouest du pays vers l'est du pays pour
deux bus en fait le premier étant de
donner aux raffineurs l'opportunité
d'avoir accès à un pétrole qui est moins
cher qui provient d'une région qui est
plus stable politiquement aussi est le
deuxième but c'est de l'exporter énergie
assez 1,1 million de baril par jour sont
comparé par exemple à 1 800 mille barils
par jour du projet keystone xl oui c'est
un gros projet c'est le pétrole qui crée
la recherche au canada en ce moment le
problème c'est ici quinze ans les états
unis n'auront plus du tout besoin de
pétrole canadien il faudra donc
l'exporter ailleurs si on n'est plus
capable d'exporter son pétrole là c'est
une question à 50 à 80 milliards qu'il
faut se poser comme canadien
et comme dans tout projet pétrolier bien
division safran
les imposants professionnel tout d'un
coup qu'ils ont le monopole du bien-être
des blogueurs quand on est chez nous à
département plein mais génial en
environnement c'est pas juste un élément
pour garder je parle de l'eau par les
iter c'est très déchirant parce que
c'est la nature ça fait partie de notre
il faut pas faut s'en préoccuper
tout le long du trajet le promoteur
n'hésite pas à faire miroiter des
retombées en termes d'emplois directs et
indirects ou encore de taxes foncières
de municipalités ou entre affaire serait
10 km par exemple ça vacille entre 170
et 200 mille dollars juste pour le
pipeline et son pays sort tant que c'est
en opération un argument de poids pour
les petites municipalités
mais pour claude lizotte ce n'est qu'une
partie de l'équation sanofi est là il ya
tellement importants qu'il est difficile
d'arriver à dire c'est une en mousse et
louis
la pression est forte des milliards sont
en jeu
qu'à regret le coeur de l'industrie
pétrolière
c'est en grande partie ici très loin de
cacouna que va se jouer l'avenir du
pipeline elle adore les gens ne
connaissent pas
donc quand on connaît pas les gens
connaissent pas la crédibilité n'est pas
encore là line mercier et
vice-présidente de l'office national de
l'énergie c'est le tribunal qui doit
analyser le projet énergie est il
soumettre ses recommandations au
gouvernement fédéral qui aura alors le
dernier mot c'est de ces deux
conseillers
l'environnement l'économie que ceux-ci
économie alors c'est pas un ou l'autre
c'est les trous les audiences la
construction
tout semble encore loin pourtant
transcanada vise la fin de 2018 pour la
mise en service du plus long oléoduc
canadien au québec tout reste à faire et
claude izod se questionne encore risqué
qui est gras qui est énorme c'est quand
on a eu trop laid
le méga projet arrive avec des règles du
jeu fraîchement redéfini par le
gouvernement fédéral michel bélanger
pratique le droit de l'environnement
depuis 25 ans une des craintes
importante c'est que on appelé pour la
première fois des amendements à une loi
qui on est important 2012 à l'égard du
probablement du projet le plus gros con
europe a eu depuis les 40 dernières
années l'office national de l'énergie a
désormais l'entière responsabilité de
l'évaluation environnementale de tout
projet de pipeline interprovincial puis
une fois qu'il aura en main l'ensemble
de la documentation du promoteur il
n'aura que quinze mois pour toutes
examinées alors qu'auparavant aucune
limite de temps n'était imposée aux
audiences fédéral ce pipeline la
traverse des milieux agricoles des
milieux sensibles des cours d'eau alors
ça fait appel à beaucoup de spécialistes
potentiellement alors je vois pas
comment le fait social énergie peut
prendre en considération tous les
aspects techniques en si peu de temps
l'objectif de la réforme du gouvernement
conservateur simplifier et accélérer le
mécanisme les investisseurs
dans le domaine de l'énergie trouvait
que les processus et terol au niveau
fédéral six provinces
quatre mille six cents kilomètres de
pipelines deux ports pétroliers
et surtout 15 mois pour examiner tous
les enjeux qui s'y rattachent le comité
d'audience va faire tout en son pouvoir
pour avoir un processus équitable parce
que c'est ce qui est important est ce
que c'est un test un projet ou si gros
que ça touche rouge et oui
ici devant l'ampleur de la tâche 15 mois
ne suffisait pas le fils nationale
pourrait demander au gouvernement une
prolongation on va commencer avec le
délai qui nous est accordée on va
essayer de faire de notre mieux et puis
ensuite on verra s'il ya des
aménagements enfants
pendant ce temps claude lizotte continue
d'observer toujours à la recherche de
réponses je vois une volonté politique
extrêmement fort que ce projet se
réalise que j'essayais d'évoluer là
dedans pour essayer très honnêtement
d'arriver à une solution dans ma tête
c'est oui ou d'un sénat
je suis président